hey guys this is what i did this weekend  i started the weekend by signing up for  a challenge where you get ten thousand  dollars if you get the most jacked in  three months odds are i probably won't  win something like this but it's always  fun to compete then a lot of you don't  know this but i actually used to live in  milwaukee that is my old roommate jenny  who i visited and any milwaukee native  knows that cop's ice cream is the best  ice cream in town i had a lot of fun  catching up with my old friends that's  shelby and ben ben is jenny's husband  and shelby is someone i did bible study  with we had dinner and drinks and had a  really really fun time then the next day  i went to church i haven't been able to  go to in-person service in a really long  time but it was so nice to see the  people that were my family when i lived  in milwaukee the kindness received from  them i'll never be able to repent